well let's speak now to Mandu Reed who's
the leader of the women's equality party
and she was at the Buckingham Palace
reception and witnessed the incident so
Maddie Reed thanks so much for talking
to us this afternoon so you were there
tell us what what you saw
yeah um we arrived at the reception and
were ushered into the main room where
the reception was taking place myself
and gozi and another campaigner were
standing together three of us black
women we were approached by a member of
the royal household who came over began
the usual small talk very quickly she
zoomed in on ngozi and asked her where
she was from and goes he said she was
from Sister space which is the
organization she leads but what followed
was almost an interrogation there was
question after question about where she
was really from where her people came
from what her nationality was and and
goes he said I'm British I was born in
the UK but that wasn't enough for this
person this person really wanted to
extract some other information about her
Heritage her African Heritage and it was
really uncomfortable in the end it was a
prolonged encounter over several minutes
and in the end it left you know all of
us feeling like perhaps we didn't belong
um at the event perhaps we weren't truly
welcome well yes and go see herself
described it as a violation didn't she
that's left her feeling stunned so how
did it leave you feeling listening to it
you know
um I also felt stunned I didn't know how
to respond
um I found myself thinking for sure if
ngozi was a white woman there's no way
that line of of questioning would have
taken place and it's not what you expect
we were invited guests to the really
important reception about a really
important subject ending violence
against women and girls we weren't gate
crashes but we were sort of made to feel
almost like trespassers and it really
took the Shine off what should have been
an important event to celebrate people
doing work that really makes a
difference in the world and raising
awareness about a crucial issue but
instead at least for the three of us who
were there in that encounter we were
left wondering if actually uh we were
kind of wanted or welcomed well yes and
just in the last few hours Buckingham
Palace have put out a statement haven't
they and they've said
um that the member of Staff concerned
has stepped aside and has offered her
profound apologies they also go on the
palace to say that they take the
incident extremely seriously they've
described the comments as unacceptable
and deeply regrettable are you reassured
At All by that reaction
you know not really because
actually I don't want to see her step
down I want to see her step up I want to
see all of them step up I want to see
the Royal household as a whole
acknowledge
um that institutional racism is part of
the culture and I want to see them
tackle that head on I I think zooming in
on this one individual doesn't really
bring any comfort it reminds me of the
whole bad apples narrative it reminds me
of the whole okay let's treat this as an
isolated incident and move on from it
approach to dealing with these issues
and and I think what's needed is
something bigger something more
substantive and something that uh really
meets the scale of of how these
incidents play out what they represent
and what they mean for people in this
country like myself like and gozi who do
belong here who are British
um but aren't necessarily received as
such and and when you say you think
there's an issue of institutional racism
when you hear their Buckingham Palace
also saying that all members of the
household are being reminded of
diversity and inclusivity policies does
that go any way towards meeting your
concerns
it's important that they've got policies
it's important that people are reminded
of them but what's more important is the
culture within the institution what's
more important is what people Experience
day to day we have heard Meghan markle's
accounts her and Harry's accounts of of
some of the things they were on the
receiving end of the experience we had
yesterday you know in a way validated
those and it was just one afternoon
reception we weren't having to
experience that day in day out so sure
policies are important but what's more
important is leadership what's more
important is acknowledging the breadth
and depth of work that needs to be done
and I think ngozi herself and her
organization have a lot of experience to
offer here they they do cultural
competence training for the Met police
for example to help them understand how
better to deal with black women who are
survivors of domestic abuse I think the
Royal household need to acknowledge that
perhaps in introducing that sort of
training
would be a meaningful first step towards
taking their institution their
organization on a journey to handling
these kind of things a whole lot better